[Musique]
il est re de retour pardon dans ce
journal pour sa chronique sports du
lundi miquel et demi d'euros bonsoir je
tenais à vous remercier vous m'avez
remplacé la semaine dernière a
brillamment je tenais à vous remercier
mais j'ai tenté de le faire de la
meilleure des manières alors pendant les
vacances scolaires il ya quand même du
sport nickel dans les yvelines on va
commencer cette chronique avec du rugby
du rugby floride j'ai effectivement joué
ce week-end en championnat de fédérale 2
il aura fallu attendre la 7e journée
pour voir le rugby club de plaisir
remporté sa première victoire de la
saison
les plaisirs roy se sont imposés et 28 à
8 face au paris université club
on écoute la réaction du capitaine
françois à le vilain au micro de manon
varaldo on sait que il nous faut
absolument une victoire il nous la
fallait absolument et je crois que tout
le monde avait à coeur de bien faire les
choses et défensivement on a su les
agresser voilà quand on avait tous envie
de bien faire les choses et
voilà ça c'est vu ça s'est senti sur le
terrain en tout cas avec cette victoire
à plaisir quitte la place de lanterne
rouge et remonte à l'avant dernière
place du championnat à seulement un
petit point à du maintien on est dans
une dans une poule qui est très
compliqué nous on est encore tout jeune
à ce niveau-là et du cou et du coup ça
demande beaucoup de travail beaucoup de
coups sacrifice d'abnégation et voilà et
tout le boulot qu'on met en place depuis
la saison depuis le début de saison
il commence à payer et je crois que
c'est ça qui fait vraiment plaisir on
progresse dans le jeu et dans
l'intensité la semaine dernière à drancy
on doit gagner là bas et aujourd'hui on
a réussi à garder le même niveau de jeu
la même intensité
prochain match pour plaisir le 11
novembre sur le terrain de chartres le
cinquième ducasse on espère que ce match
se passera aussi bien que le précédent
pour les plaisirs ou en continu par du
football
allez je présente je prononce bien
nickel la coupe de france ce week end le
6e tour de la coupe de france les
yvelines auront deux représentants au
prochain tour de la compétition
versailles club de nationale 3 s'est
imposé sur la plus petite des marges
contre nanterre qui évolue en r 2 score
final 1-0 autres qualifiés cariat
grésillons les événements remporté le
derby contre verneuil sur seine à
domicile s'impose 1 à 0 et devienne le
plus le petit poucet national de cette
coupe de france
c'est terminé en revanche pour poitiers
qui s'incline aux tirs au but contre
drancy le prochain tour est programmé
dans trois semaines des yvelinois
connaîtront leur adversaire mercredi
prochain vous souhaite bonne chance à
nosy be noël merci michael ces résultats
bien d'autres encore à suivre dans votre
émission et l'apparence on verra ça le
7-8 sport s'est assuré après lé journal